we got a movie going for best comedy of
the year and it is the predator the
predator so the Predators the newest
movie in the predator franchise directed
by Shane Black who directed Iron Man 3
that will be important in a bit
basically new predator comes to earth
and then there's a bigger predator who
followed him and there's one guy in his
family and this new unit is a military
guy so I guess they're a unit but
they're essentially crazy they get
caught in the middle so they've got to
kind of figure it out get basic really
vague synopsis of a movie here there's a
new predator movie that for the most
part takes place in the suburbs I was
like I don't know but there were some
things that worked in this movie when
this movie gets down to it you get
yourself some good predator gore it's
entertaining I mean some mindless
entertainment is just violent
entertainment but you can't help but
smile pretty bloody fantastic in some
scenes some kills actually make you
laugh - one kill in particular I died
laughing it was hilarious gonna speak on
the humour a lot here because the humor
is a main part of this movie this movie
if I had to classify it I guess I
classified it's a comedy a little
strange if this movie has this much
humour it being Shane Black he did that
with Iron Man 3
that's me telling you this predator
movie has MCU style humor in it it's not
just a little strange at times it's
inconsistent also there's so much of
that humor in this movie that at a point
when the movie wants to be a little more
serious the audience doesn't know how to
take it there was one scene that I felt
like it wasn't supposed to be funny it
was actually supposed to be kind of
sentimental and half the audience
chuckling the other half you could just
tell they're trying to figure it out
like this kind of like imagine for an
hour and a half you're in a car with
somebody who's driving and they're like
hey you want to get a good dessert I
know a good place for dessert dessert
baby it's really sweet you're gonna get
yourself some desert desert desert
desert get that in your head you're
gonna get yourself some good sweet
dessert for an hour and a half and you
eat the dessert it kind of tastes like
french fries which goes with milkshakes
I don't care what anyone says who
doesn't dip the fries in milkshake but
the point is if it doesn't taste like
dessert you're like is it just bad
dessert or is it is it a dessert at all
you're left trying to figure it out it
was that kind of inconsistent in part
action blood and humor I could see like
if keegan-michael key was the one who
was the comic relief maybe him and
Thomas J I feel like it would work
better predator had that which is funny
because Shane black the director of this
movie was in the original predator movie
and his character had some jokes
Shayne Blackwell directing this movie
was like I'll take that one element of
my character in the original predator
movie and make that every character in
this predator movie I can stare at you
boldface and tell you this movie had
more humor than dr. strange and I get it
like the emcee used me billions of
dollars this year alone but in
hollywood's quest to capture that
lightning in a bottle I would just I
would want them to know that that kind
of MCU humor doesn't translate well to
everything it's a predator movie
predator is about this alien being who
cloaks in the forest hunts you kills you
and rip your spine out that's pretty
frightening when you think about it I
don't know that it lends itself to the
MCU style humor but I kind of get it
like where else could they go with
predator in the jungle seeing it in the
city saying it isolated in the Arctic
maybe saying it suburbs
nope saying it ha multiple predators
warring factions of predators seen it
predator versus bigger predator in the
suburbs I don't know if that's different
enough how did your versus bigger
predator in the suburbs but it's funny I
like Star Wars humor and see you here
we're baby pretty sure that's the same
thing we're gonna call the predator
humor words out with yeah they've done
it all before at that point the question
is should they have like if there was
just a new movie about warring aliens
who come to the suburbs and it just
plays out like this movie it's just not
predator that probably be fine but it's
not an established franchise so it's not
marketable and so Hollywood just doesn't
really like doing that they're like
making things that people already know
because that's the thing to do I feel
like some of the jokes some people will
find offensive like some people on
Twitter in Hollywood I'm gonna narrow
the bubble down but I'm a sick in the
head heartless soulless bastard so I
don't care that it made me laugh doesn't
change the fact that at a point when
you're seeing so much humor in this
movie just comes across as kind of
strange I speak on the mixed signals
this movies thrown at us because this is
one guy he's like the main government
guy in the movie you're supposed to see
this guy's like this stone-cold killer
like who were supposed to be afraid of
him but I wasn't for so long because it
was funny he's cracking jokes he's like
this charismatic likable guy probably
hang out with just how frightening this
movie apparently was supposed to make
this guy feel to hell frightening he
actually came across was just it was
completely unbalanced and that came from
the fact that he was one of the many
characters by many I mean every one of
them in this movie
who's cracking jokes also the people
this movie I feel like they're idiots
like the logic doesn't make sense yeah
I'm looking for logic in a movie about
aliens that turn invisible and on people
I know that can be the argument what I'm
looking for is consistency in the rules
really consistency in judgment among
people when this super predator shows up
on the scene it's established early on
that bullets really have a little effect
on it so when everyone at the end of the
movies making their last stand with guns
that shoot bullets I just have to think
they're idiots they're morons like who
would make that call they need Keanu
Reeves from Constantine to come out of
nowhere and be like that's really not
gonna help Constantine you remember she
raised her gun - what she didn't know as
a demon he just said that's really not
gonna help so right they're like all
right guns are ineffective let's not use
them like do they need to be told
do they not trust their eyes so right
there I feel like it's the illusion of
tension not real tension it might as
well be unarmed guys in the end they did
something new with predator which I get
doing new things like this I've never
worn this jacket in a video before kind
of wanted to because I've never done it
before and I'd like this jack really
predators in a tough spot it's a movie
that happened that turned into a
franchise that happen well what made it
really cool was the fact that this thing
was hunting them and no one knew what it
was it was an invisible thing and then
it did cloaks you're like it has a mask
what is it and it takes off its mask and
then you see what it is but now everyone
knows what the predator looks like and
what it is so now instead of a thing
hunting people this thing's kind of a
brute like imagine a movie that's about
a ninja and that's what made it cool
thing hunts in the shadows dude kills
people stealthily within decades later
they make a new one with a bigger ninja
that's not actually a ninja that doesn't
hunt in the shadows this thing's like a
tank - strolling up slaughtering people
in order to say it's less cool this
movie's entertaining but the last act
ended kind of anticlimactic and the very
last scene happen and I was like what's
this there's enjoyment in this
movie is probably more enjoyable if
you're drunk yeah I know it's a book
well what to do well we'll give you the
predator soundtrack about that mind
manipulation I see what you're
doing new predator remove it using the
old predator theme that's a cheap move
but I also know why they're doing it
they're doing it to manipulate the
audience if the audience forgets those
parts that don't feel like predator all
right so the predator have you seen it
what did you think about it or what's
your favorite to least favorite predator
movies that includes a VP if you want to
include them whatever they're whatever
you think comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]